foreign
no longer really can sleep in the same
bed together at night because he makes
so much noise and I'm a very light
sleeper I feel so guilty that we're not
sharing the same bed every night but I
don't really know what the right answer
is
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is John the Dr John
deloney show
and I had way too much caffeine this
morning
and I've been trying to tone it down for
the last few months but
I'm running on all cylinders and I
borrowed a few other cylinders chemical
cylinders and they are firing all the
same time I'm so glad you're here on the
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast ever ever ever
conceived that's not true none of what I
just said it's true but I'm so glad that
you're here on this show we talked to
real people who man life is just
came for him right I get us for all of
us marriage issues dealing with kids
dealing with physical stuff dealing with
mental and emotional health Diagnostics
whatever you got going on and here's my
promise on this show I'll sit with you
and we will figure out what to do next
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's 1-844-693-3291
let's run out to Kimberly in Atlanta
Georgia what's up Kimberly
hey I'm glad to hear that you're
germinated this morning because I'm very
sleepy I am borderline messed so we're I
mean I'm real close what's up
so
my husband I've been married for about
25 years and I'm just trying to
determine how we can maintain our I
guess marital Health
um in the fact that we no longer really
can sleep in the same bed together at
night because he makes so much noise and
I'm a very light sleeper and so I feel
so guilty that we're not sharing the
same bed every night but I don't really
know what the right answer is
oh so this is this is like a contentious
conversation in the nerd World
um so
talk to me about the conversation jail
had to get to this point
whatever it sounds you know snoring or
even just like Breathing heavily or
whatever that he makes
um I want to lean in right there I want
to lean in right there
he feels awful and yeah I literally had
a conversation with somebody a few days
ago a buddy of mine
and I said and I quote and again there's
a very particular person with a very
particular set of circumstances I said
I'll put a thousand dollars on the table
that if you cut out grains and sugars
for 60 to 90 days you're you're snoring
an apnea would would curb dramatically
and he looked at me and he goes I know
you're exactly right
and so when you tell me
um he feels terrible about it my next
question is always how terrible terrible
enough to to go to a sleep doctor
terrible enough to start changing things
and start trying things or just terrible
like I feel bad
oh right and goes right back to it
I mean you know I think he'd be willing
to go have a sleep study done we
actually did talk about that just like a
month or so ago and he said he'd be open
to it
um and it's not even so much snoring
it's just he's a very loud breather at
night like he's a mouse breeder
and I'm such a light sleeper that the
slightest sounds wake me up so then I
feel like it's my fault because I don't
you know I'm I'm just too sensitive so
it's just been it's just been a funny
thing that's been going on for with us
for like the last couple years okay so
here's I'll I
there's nothing nothing hotter like
erotically than looking over at an open
mouth-to-mouth breather right it's half
it was like cash to the world and it's
just
oh man yeah
um and Okay so
that's probably a picture none of us
needed in our heads so
um I it is funny and also I'm gonna make
it a little more serious is that cool
yes all right so serious number one
um I would be willing to bet again I
don't have a lot but I'd be willing to
bet that he is not sleeping continuously
for more than four hours a night and
maybe tosses and turns and gets a five
or six or seven I would love love love
for him to go get a Garmin watch and
just begin tracking his sleep
hmm okay because almost no say almost
always
a significant amount of the time there
is underlying pathologies underlined and
it can be as simple as as it is in my
case which is uh for some reason I got
some weird food allergies that my body
just does weird things so in my house
um my wife we have a very similar
Dynamic except
um I have a wife who's a it was a
researcher and so she began to just
quietly track
what because some nights I would snore
and some nights I would sleep like she
would have to reach over and touch my
chest because she thought I died in my
sleep I was just so out and
um
she began to track it and she landed on
three things beer pizza and candy
period and if I have those three things
I will snore for some reason my body
swells does something on the inside and
I used to try to dig out the physiology
I don't care anymore what I know is
those three things are to be true are
true and when I went and started
tracking my sleep first with a woop
strap and then with the this garment I
wear now
um by the way I've got no affiliation
with either of those companies they just
Garmin is just a tremendous product
um
I noticed that my sleep was was
deleterious on those nights like it was
it was half of what it normally is
and so now I know
one thing to be true
if I do and if I have a beer with some
buddies if I have some pizza or if I eat
some candy I am making a conscious
choice to snore
I'm also making a conscious noise to
sleep in another bedroom
I'm also making a conscious decision to
not sleep very well
and I occasionally do that because my
time with my friends or my wife or my
family or whatever's going on it's worth
that trade but it is very much in my
life very much an either or
and that's simply because I got so
curious number one number two my wife
got curious number three I took very
seriously the fact that I was disrupting
her life in that in that way
yeah and so I think your husband like
sounds like he likes the idea
of you having a good night's sleep but
not enough to just go all in
because I got I got insane about it
yeah I think he just thinks that
he can't control yeah
with him that there is maybe something
that can be done about it a whole bunch
she actually does eat pretty healthy but
at the same time I'm sure that I could
start looking at it and tracking it just
to see if there is because it's like you
said it's not every night some nights he
sleeps great and I can stay put and then
other nights you know he's just ripping
and roaring and I'm like I'm going to
the other bedroom again I'm not a sleep
study guy I'm a sleep study expert
um
I I would be willing to bet there's some
some sort of allergic reaction side of
him and I say allergies I'm speaking
very Loosely they're not in a clinical
sense in any way but all it says is
here's where there's there's a big
discussion back and forth in the nerd
World there are some studies that say
over the long haul that sleeping in
separate beds does disrupt your sex life
it does disrupt your intimacy life and
it might even have some Downstream
Health consequences and there's some
other studies that say
Above All Else get a good night's sleep
nothing in your life matters
um nothing nothing you can do in your
life matters if it's built on a
foundation of less than good sleep
and so in my house and I again this is
one of those like there's no consensus
in the literature so I'm just gonna tell
you what I do
um probably one night a week maybe two
I'll sleep another room
because I've made some dumb Choice
um maybe yeah that's not true maybe once
every two weeks I will I'll sleep in the
guest room
yeah and it's it's a gift for her it's a
gift for me I also know about once a
month maybe twice a month I will I'll
know about eight o'clock like oh man I'm
gonna be up to four I don't know why my
buddy does that it just does and I used
to fight it and fight it and fight it in
Medicaid I just don't fight it at all
anymore I just get a lot of work done
it's great and I make sure I do my
workouts
um early that next morning and then my
body just adjusts itself and so I don't
fight anymore and but what is important
is I want to make sure
um at least one of us is sleeping good
so I make sure she gets some sleep and
she'll tell you right
um she does not sleep when I'm snoring
and she sleeps at a different level when
I'm in and in the same bed
and my guess is you experience that I'm
missing that's right because you know we
used to have that and you know I love
that closeness and you know just that
security feeling so I it's just been
hard because then like I said I feel
guilty when I'm not sleeping in there
that I'm like oh I'm shunning you or
whatever so that's that's good right now
the greatest gift you could give your
husband is a well-rested you
yeah the greatest gift he could give you
is to really dig in and figure out why
his body has begun acting the way it has
been over the last few
um months years
um I think it's a formal sleep study is
great I think before you would pay the
money to go to a formal sleep study I
think it would be fun just to track
I think it'd be fun just to track and so
here's how this would look in your house
you go ahead and set up the guest room
as though you're gonna sleep in there
and then you get ready and go to bed
and if he wakes you up in the middle of
the night y'all have written down what
y'all ate the night before
and it might be as simple as that
it might also be as simple as a meeting
coming up that he had or didn't have I
would look at the simplest things first
and I would do anything
to not have pizza and a dark beer and
Candy slash chips and queso I would do
anything for those four things not to
affect my body in that way but they do
they do and they don't affect my friends
in that same way which is super annoying
but they do
and ask me choosing reality I gotta live
in that so you are not a bad person
you're not your marriage isn't falling
apart all those none of that stuff is
true those are all stories that we got
from Leave it to Beaver right
um I don't even know why I said leave to
Beaver but if you are new to the world
that shows about a thousand years old
but what's important is you all decide
I want to sleep in the same bed as you
you want to sleep in the same bed as me
that means we have to get to the bottom
of this we have to figure it out and
let's get very curious and very aware of
what's going on and then if we can't
figure that out and over the next two
weeks this doesn't take a long time like
this is this is a couple of weeks then
let's go get a formal sleep study let's
go figure that out let's go see if
there's something with jaw alignment or
with the way my my pillow work I mean
there's any number of things
um but almost always underneath like a
sudden and I say the last couple years a
sudden snoring sudden deep breathing you
start heading into sleep apnea that
waking up and go to sleep waking up
going to sleep you're getting into some
underlying pathology that your body is
trying to get your attention about and
it's just good go get checked out it's
good we'll get it checked out but this
all starts with you sitting on your
husband saying I've been getting some
sleep but I miss you
would you be willing to not just talk
about it but let's get very very serious
about figuring out
what's happening to your body at night
and let's see if we can figure that out
and it might cost you uh your nightly
ball of ice cream it might cost you that
glass of wine it might cost you whatever
but am I worth it
don't do that that would be mean but I
mean also do that all right thanks for
the call you're awesome we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey good folks Dr John deloney here can
we all just take a minute to take a deep
breath
ah there's a lot going on especially in
the economy you're hearing words like
recession continued inflation thrown
around and it's making your stress
levels Spike I don't care who you are
but remember we've been through Seasons
like this before and the best thing you
can do is focus on controlling what you
can control you can control your
spending and saving you can you can
control your daily habits you can
and you can control making time for
sleep and this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I found
that the key to good sleep starts with
an incredible mattress and that's why I
love dream Cloud mattresses they're
incredibly comfortable and right now
dream cloud is making it easy to invest
in good sleep with their biggest offer
yet 40 off all mattresses plus an
additional fifty dollars in savings
exclusively for my listeners go to
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
and start sleeping today
all right let's go out to Charlotte and
talk to Pam which is map backwards
what's up Pam how we doing
uh not much just hanging in there very
cool aren't we all right what's up
oh I've been having some difficulty
sticking with
uh for lack of a better word ultimatums
that I've been trying with my husband
who has a mental illness uh ultimatums
are never great they're never good what
ultimatums did you put down
well uh so he has agoraphobia he's not
left our house at all for
and
it wouldn't be so bad except for like he
he also wants to keep me and our kids at
home yeah that's yeah yikes
um
we've had several showdowns about it and
I'm always the one who backs down
you've been in prison for three years
yeah you can't do that anymore
no no your kids can't do that either
no
um
yeah you didn't make a call on this ASAP
there is
um so for those listening agoraphobia
it's technically classified as an
anxiety
disorder but agoraphobia agoraphobia is
initially a fear of large crowds right
when I don't know how I'm going to get
out of this situation and it
increasingly tightens your circle and
you may experience or imagine panic
attacks and then over time if un
untreated and undebt with and by the way
especially up front it's not a hard
um it's not a hard
um
Mental Health Challenge to to overcome I
mean it's pretty systematic but over
time untreated agoraphobics don't leave
their house they won't they'll they'll
shut the door lock the door they will
draw the curtains and then where it gets
really dire is when they trap loved ones
in the house too
and that sounds like where y'all are at
right
yeah well we're living this kind of half
left where uh I'll go to my parents
house with the kids for a few weeks
and he set up we have a two-story home
so he set up like basically an apartment
with a makeshift kitchen
you aren't even married
we offer uh two weeks every month and a
half
when he when he's done hiding from us
yeah yeah that I mean
that's not marriage
is he unwilling to go get go get help
uh he's he's
tried so he's on a Team Six
and then if they want him to leave the
house or well say that one more time I
missed it
oh I'm sorry he's he's on attempt six of
getting help or he's he's reached out to
mental health professional but for
whatever reason he's always backed out
before so he's not getting help yeah
um
and he's unwilling what is What is the
what is his narrative
uh
so so he has OCD uh contamination
and so his his narrative is that if he
gets sick he's going to he's going to
die and then he's protecting us and that
whenever we do anything normal you know
go to the park we're risking illness
ourselves
yeah
what does he yeah and I want people to
hear that with an agoraphobic especially
somebody who's man you throw an OCD on
top of that which by the way I'm still
in the camp that those are
those are are similar I know there's
some neurological differences there but
I think the trajectory from anxiety to
OCD and back
um
are pretty tightly wound
um are braided together there
um but it is life or death so if you see
um like you're about to step in a
rattlesnake is about to strike you and
I'm talking to people who are listening
here
um not to you Pam but if you are about
to step on a rattlesnake or a car is
coming at you and it's 10 feet away
that's the feeling that that he gets
when he's about to go outside or when
you all have been at the park or been at
a grocery store and you come just be
bopping back in the house
um
how old are your kids
four and a half and two oh geez yeah
um
you have to make some hard calls here
quick Pam
and I know that you know that but I just
want to reaffirm you're not crazy and
your husband's worthy of being loved and
all that
but you can't do this much longer and
those kids cannot be penned up and
they're they cannot have their nervous
system wired and it already is down the
road especially for your oldest one that
they are somehow a contamination to
their dad
you know what I mean yeah yeah
and that they I mean it's it's for a
child's nervous system to be in the same
room or the same that's why covid was so
awful
for folks who had to go upstairs for two
weeks and quarantine their little kids
are downstairs and they just couldn't
wrap their head around it and that this
isn't just for two weeks this is for
ever in your home and my guess is this
this tends to escalate so it just slowly
moves is that how this has been going
for the last several years
it escalated escalated and then you know
he he got a little better he got a
little looser on things uh mostly I have
to kind of just say no and stand up to
them and so you know he's loosened up
quite a bit you know but
that that's um
anybody outside looking in wouldn't even
notice that he's he's loosened up and
he's gotten better
um
what's your relationship with your
parents meaning could you move in on a
permanent basis for a season
yeah yeah here's here's the way I want
you to think of this
at the end of the day
not that your husband has chosen
agoraphobia not that your husband has
chosen anxiety or OCD
he has chosen up until now and I know
can also be a function of the illness so
I'm not cold-hearted and evil or all
that
but he has chosen to not
pursue care
and he hasn't had to
um and so
um
at the end of the day you have to choose
what's best for you and your children
and you know as well as I do this
scenario is not sustainable and it's not
good for your kids
and it's not good for you
and so there will be a lot of grief
there will be a lot of guilt there will
be a lot of
um trying to figure out what comes next
and who knows what comes next
but this isn't about ultimatums this is
about health the health of you and your
kids
yeah
phrases it as an ultimatum when I talk
to him about it that's the way he does
that's that's how he keeps us his hooks
in you
yeah you're not giving him an ultimatum
what you're going to do from this point
forward is do the things that you need
to do to stay well in whole
and that is I'm not going to be I'm not
going to be held a prisoner in my own
home I just won't be our children are
going to go out and play with other kids
because they have to have that for
neurological development our kids are
going to go outside and get sunshine and
have different adventures and they're
going to have different tactile
experiences lateral horizontal uh
they're going to do all of these things
for their neural development not stay
locked inside this house watching TV
period
your dream and hope and I hope you
communicate this to him
my dream and hope is
that and I will go every step of the way
with you
if you'll have me
um my dream and hope is that you will
begin ASAP
to get the mental health care that you
need
because for agoraphobia for OCD for for
hyper anxiety disorders there's
significant help available
yeah there is and for agoraphobia
specifically now he's he sounds like
he's really far down the road has he had
started the panic attack process yet
not that I've seen he it's mostly just
like not sleeping is where I see it like
not about ability not to sleep where I
see it kinda
and I have I have a working hypothesis
that I may be crazy on but I have a
hypothesis that my anxiety did not get
super super super bad like like
irrationally bad
I've always been uh just just hyper
sensitive like uh able to read a room
able to know like oh there's about to be
a fight like I I it's all I've been that
way since I was a little kid but my
anxiety didn't get out of control until
I spent several years taking hypnotic
sleep medications
because I was training
um mixed martial arts and from 8 to 10
p.m I'd get home really late and then I
could just take this thing and it would
knock me out what I didn't realize over
time was I was not sleeping my body was
not getting restored of sleep I was just
unconscious through this medication and
I thought I had hacked the system right
and so it was several years of not
sleeping well that I spun out
and so it may be and again we're talking
chicken or the egg here but I'm
wondering what six or seven weeks of
Deep
black hole sleep not hip not hypnosis
and not unconsciousness but of sleep
would do to his ability to think
rationally about what comes next
he has to choose that
and let me be super clear I quit my job
we took a seventy thousand dollar
household income pay cut we moved
I did all kinds of things that were
Radical and insane at the time I turned
down a vice presidency I did a lot of
stuff
because I love my wife and I love my
kids and I didn't want this I didn't
want this anymore
and so I tell you that to tell you it
might take huge sacrifices
and I'm here more than a decade later
and every single
inch of my life every single corner of
my life is different
yeah and I'm dude I'm no superhero but
my wife laid down some really firm
boundaries
and she was right to do so
what's your what is your hang up
uh
I I guess just lots of guilt for for
leaving him leaving a minute
is you staying in it doing anything
positively to help him
uh
what about the guilt you should have
towards yourself
or the guilt you should have towards
your kids that are seeing all this
yeah so it's it's it's just a
a lot of not feeling great yeah exactly
so here's what I'm trying to get you
um I wrote about this in this new book
there's only a hard path
it's hard to to sit down with your
parents and say we're going to move in
for six months we're going to try a six
month separation here
and you could tell your husband I'm not
interested in divorcing you I'm not but
I can no longer sit in this home while
you drown
in isolation and loneliness
yeah I can't I can't watch you do that
and I especially am not going to let our
four-year-old and two-year-old watch you
do this
and so I'm going to get them Community
I'm gonna get them sunshine I'm gonna
get them activity I'm gonna go see a
counselor because this has been really
hard on me the last three years watching
my husband slowly suffocate inside his
own house our own house
um but I'm gonna live here for 90 days
for three months for six months
the moment you need a ride to go see a
mental health professional I will be
there
yeah right so this is an abandonment
this is at this point you've made you're
continuing down this path I'm gonna I'm
gonna choose to make sure that me and my
our two little kids are okay because
that's my job
yeah that's my job
and I want you to make sure your picture
of what marriage is
oh let me go back you've got two hard
paths leaving will be hard
um being a single mom for a season with
your parents will be hard they're
probably some I told you so's and all
that some worst Daddy all that stuff
and staying in this current
psychosis
sitting in this dark house upstairs
where you're I mean it's just Madness
right when you say it out loud you're
like is this my life that's hard that's
hard too so that yeah you have you have
a hard path either way take the one
that's going to lead you towards healing
I think the one that's going to be
safest for your kids
does that make sense you hear what I'm
saying that makes sense
nothing you've done up till now is
working let's try something completely
different and be prepared for the guilt
be prepared for his
um gaslighting and oh my gosh you
abandoned me you left me you're the
worst when I needed you most
all that stuff you know that's coming
right yeah that's the stuff it gets me
of course you know so you know that it
is a
person that's him saying I don't want to
actually
make the call to the professional I
don't want to call the fire department
to put this fire out I just want you to
sit with me and get burned to
yeah
yeah that's that's it
don't get burned anymore
I would go in that fire and get you if
it was to get you out and get you to the
professionals that can help
but you don't want that right now and
that's okay you're an adult you get to
do that I'm gonna be heartbroken and
sick over watching my my the man I love
go through this and not accept anybody's
help
but also I'm not going to sit in the
fire with you anymore
right
and hear me say this agoraphobia it's
there's desensitization where they they
have you imagine things they have you
draw a picture of things and they sit
with you and they teach you some skills
and then there's usually panic attacks
involved and they teach you to work
through those but we're not talking and
then you you roll off into cognitive
behavioral therapy at some point we're
not talking a complex process out of
this
okay
yeah
um this is him choosing like I don't
want this life anymore
and I don't know what to do it feels
insane I feel like I'm gonna die all
those things are true I'm not saying
this is easy or trivial by any means
yeah yeah I I I I I believe he doesn't
want to get help because he's he's
afraid that getting helpful exposed into
what he thinks is going to kill him and
here's the deal in his mind he's exactly
right yeah how does how does he make
money
oh that's that's the crazy thing he runs
three successful businesses from the
house with employees and everything none
of his friends know how sick he is
he's like super high functioning
business guy
wow so yeah good for him good for him
yeah good for him
can't check the mail but you know
that was kind of a dig but I appreciate
it I like a good dick
yeah I make six figures and can't go
check the mail but I mean that's that's
a that's a function right of geez Louise
yeah I hate that Forum I hate that for
everybody involved hit for everybody
involved
um but let's let's go back and
he doesn't want to call 9-1-1
his house is on fire I don't want to
call 9-1-1 he just wants you to sit with
him and hold his hand and if you get up
and say I'm tired of getting burned
you're the bad guy you're not you're not
the bad guy
you're not the bad guy I don't think
he's a bad guy
and he has enough working in his life
that he has not been
forced with a face with an either or so
he's been able to keep his money coming
in his work from home his imaginary
leadership with employees virtual and
his marriage in some weirdly constructed
two weeks here you do this I'm going
over here you go over there
weirdness
um
he's been able to keep all the plates
spinning and this is when you come in
and say I'm getting off I'm not on your
plates anymore I'm going over here until
you choose to get well
and he's gonna feel like he's walking
through hell and for his body he will be
and
you're worth it and so are those little
kids
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of building a non-anxious life this
is y'all's world
and this is what comes next
and these are the aspects when he sits
down and after going through the
exposure therapy
um
he is going to
have to create a new world y'all have to
create a new world together and this is
your road map building a non-anxious
life all of y'all are worth more than
this we'll be right back
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloney today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hollow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right let's go out to Los Angeles
the City of Angels and talk to Justin
what's up Justin how we doing
hey Dr doley how's it going it's an
honor to be talking with you we're
partying man it's honor to talk to you
dude what's up
yeah so my situation
um
basically so ever since I was a kid um
ever since I was little my dream was to
uh was to become an airline pilot
um and so I kind of pursued that dream
I went to college after college became a
commercial pilot and flight instructor
but then due to some medical and mental
health stuff I actually wasn't able to
continue past that and
um since really flying was my identity
it kind of put me in a rough spot for a
while really felt like I had kind of
lost my purpose
um and it's it's gotten better since
then I've been going I've had gone to
some counseling and I'm enjoying what
I'm doing now but it still pops up here
and there and I've I've kind of found
myself
um like whenever I drive by at an
airport I I start feeling pretty low and
it feels like kind of I'm going back to
square around to square one so my guess
my question overall is how I can kind of
begin to fully Let It Go and move on and
embrace what's ahead yeah man thanks for
the call so um what put this picture in
your head as a kid just curious
yeah I I've thought about that it I mean
nobody in my family were pilots or
anything like that it was just something
that I've always kind of been into
everything that moves trains planes
boats and
um planes just caught my eye and that's
kind of what drew me toward it from a
young age yeah I was recently
sitting down with somebody and we were
kind of doing some
mining of of my past and
it occurred to me that my dad used to
really talk positive so my dad you know
was a hostage negotiator for the SWAT
team and
um there was a psychologist on staff
like a staff psychologist with the with
the police department that was kind of
over everything and my dad used to talk
about that guy with reverence
like we would be he'd say like we were
dealing with issue issue issue issue
we'd call in the wake him up middle of
the night tell him he'd go just ask him
this and we'd always ask him and he
would just the guy was that was about to
jump would just come down or the guy who
had a bomb which would just walk out the
front door and so I had to wonder man I
always hear my dad talk about this one
guy with such reverence is that the tiny
Mustard Seed of you should be in mental
health and then your dad will think he's
your dad would be proud of you too and I
just wondered and so I always love to
ask that question where is that seed
especially from a young age
um
who in your life or what in your life
planted that seed but who knows what it
is right I just wondered if you were
like no my dad used to be a pilot or he
used to talk how amazing Pilots were or
my mom anyway my mom a pilot saved my
mom's life or anything
yeah no I haven't I haven't found
anything like that that I can think of
it was just more of the fact that I
loved airplanes and everything like that
so that's very cool all right so what's
the medical issue man what happened well
yeah so it started with
um well it started I was flying one time
um just by myself I was building
building some hours for one of my
certificates and I'm just out of nowhere
really out of nowhere my my toes my
fingers all started going dangly and
numb
um and I started to kind of my vision
started to go away and I I really
thought like I was going to black out
and that was going to be it right there
um and I remember yeah it was that was
just a that was the first instance of it
and so I thought it was carbon monoxide
poisoning from um from the airplane but
it turns out that was not the case I
went to see some doctors and some panic
attacks that's that's what they had told
me that it most likely was yeah and so
those started coming back and I had a
whole bunch of those and I ended up
finishing the program successfully but
after that it was I always kind of left
at this Crossroads I was like you know
as as a flight instructor my primary
responsibility is going to be to ensure
the safety of the whoever's in my
airplane and I can't do that right now
it's just not really going to be the
suitable option so did you take yourself
out
uh yeah I did okay yeah
can I give you an alternative hypothesis
yeah absolutely there's the obvious loss
man you put your whole life into this
and you trained for it you got certified
in it you had this vision of this life
you became an instructor right I mean
this was your world
but there's also another component when
your body betrays you
and that's the part underneath the job
that's the part underneath the identity
part where suddenly just walking on two
feet becomes unstable because the one
thing that you rely on every day failed
you in your eyes have failed you
yeah yeah
that to me is the core angst
because I don't trust me anymore if I
don't trust me I can't trust anybody
anything at all
yeah is that fair
yeah that's definitely fair so my
question for you would be what's the
core
anxiety underneath this because panic
attack is your body trying to get
basically a panic attack is your your
body's saying hey you haven't listened
to us we're out I quit
um yeah what's under what's the core
anxiety underneath that
yeah that's um
I don't know I mean yeah that's I think
that's the question I'm kind of seeking
answers for as well
uh because yeah it tends to
it's been a while since I've had one but
it always tend to happen when
not in places where I didn't feel in
control but in times where I felt that
if it happened then it would be in worst
case scenario so flying obviously is
when it would start to happen the most
and then driving they would happen
pretty often too other than that it
would it never seemed to affect my life
in in ways other than that I guess but
there's my guess is there's an
underlying so think of it this way you
have a cup like a glass
and it can take a lot
you can take your got to be at work on
time you got a wife it's that's hassling
you about something you got a kid that's
got the flu you've got Mom and Dad who
are telling you what you're doing for
Christmas it's got all these things and
and it's each one of them is putting
like um drops of water in this glass and
it fills up and up and up and you got
that car payment you got to make and you
got that soccer coach telling you that
your kid's gonna be the one but you're
going to have to pay for private lessons
and you get this exam tomorrow for your
licensure all the stuff just keeps going
up and up and up
and then your glass is completely full
and then you get in a plane and you know
more so than the people on the plane
that you're super jittery and you didn't
sleep and you had 19 cups of coffee to
get the day going
and then the the Thought Machine kicks
up
and so what I want you to look at it is
not the about the Thought Machine that
thought machine is trying to keep you
safe
that panic attack is trying to keep you
I want to go underneath it and say what
in your life is filling up your glass so
tall
that when stress comes which I hope
honestly I hope my Pilots I have a lot
of flights coming up here I'll be
traveling a lot I hope all my Pilots are
a little bit angsty
no I don't want them to have anxiety
disorders but I want them all to be like
hey we need to do this right I don't
want them just cruising man you know so
I want you to be like all right we're
got focused we're lasered in not like ah
man you see the game last night because
in my head that just means we're all
gonna have we're all gonna wreck and so
my question for you is
how's your underlying health
how's your underlying relationships
how is
um your underlying autonomy who who runs
your life
how's your marriage
is these are questions I want to get to
the bottom of because if you have an
empty glass or a glass that's very very
um small here's here's the story I love
to tell from stage
when my cousin died suddenly
like man it was awful and my wife and I
booked plane tickets and we got a hotel
in Houston we flew home
we were never anxious
man I was sad
I be but because my glass is empty most
of the time I don't owe anybody any
money I don't I work I see a counselor
regularly I work on my marriage really
hard I always try to be a better dad
like
because I'm not anxious when bad stuff
happens there's enough space in that
glass for me to accept whatever water
gets dumped into it
and my body doesn't shut us down because
it's prepared you see what you see the
analogy I'm getting at
yeah yeah
and maybe it's none of those things
I think more the the thought that I come
back to the most
I really think is the
is the idea that I'm like not where I
thought I would be
like I guess when it pops up I guess
when I when I see pictures of friends
that I was in flight school with who are
now making it to the Airlines and I feel
that sense of
um
I don't even really know how to describe
it but that's that's kind of I mean
that's where I see it the most it's just
jealousy and that's totally normal I'd
be jealous right
yeah
totally yeah
but I also think in the short term you
did a really Noble thing opting out
because you could have gone through
flight school and got up in a plane and
no one would have known what you were
feeling in your shoes
Fair
yeah
yeah 100 no one would have known until
you blacked out and left that other
pilot all by himself
so for me the figuring out what is that
underlying anxiety about
because the trainers the certifiers the
instructors they believe in you
those who have ridden with you before
they believe in you your students have
believed in you the one thing that
doesn't believe in you is your body for
some reason
yeah and I'd want to get to the core of
that
the second piece on the alternative what
are you doing now
for non-profit and I'm also going back
to back to school what are you doing
there
that's a non-profit no no no going back
to school for what
I'm getting a master's in counseling ah
there you go okay so have you gone to
your own therapy
yeah yeah I have yeah you haven't got to
the bottom of the anxiety
yeah I
it doesn't yeah I guess it doesn't seem
like we have
ah I yeah
come on counselors I
yeah come on counselors
um
I guess I thought I was I thought yeah I
guess I thought I was
farther past this than I'm
realizing now just I guess with things
that keep popping up so when people get
cancer
when people end up with a brain tumor
when people
um who are star athletes blow their knee
out
there is a it's different than a Formula
One driver whose car wrecks on them
because they there's a gap between that
car and them
when your body fails you
it's devastating
because if I can't again because if I
can't rely on my body good God man and
there's always a coming back around that
after the next five years we are gonna
go to the doctor and see if we're cancer
if cancer is still undetectable
is it undetectable is it undetectable
and there's that apprehension there's
that that
um anxiousness and that's good that's
right
because your body let you down
in in this in this analogy right I don't
think globally it lets you down but
um the picture you had was we're gonna
do this thing and your body's like we're
not gonna do that
yeah and so I think there is a there
will be some it will take time to make
peace with
that's not for me
or in this season that wasn't for me
are you done flying forever can you
never do it again
I think
why
I mean
I mean unless I can get to a point where
I know for certain I could do it safely
I wouldn't want to you can only do that
in the air
yeah yeah exactly exactly
and is the thought of getting back up in
the air just terrify you just get that
warm feeling in your guts
yeah and it it really did ever since
because when that when it first happened
that was still months away from when I
was finished and so really ever since
that ever since that day getting back in
there
um was pretty tough and and that even
that was when I had somebody else with
me
um and so going back by my by myself I
just I don't know how I just don't know
how my body would react to that all
right here's what I want you to do and
if your therapist can't do this I want
you to find somebody in your local
community who can do this and out there
in California I promise you can find
this
I want somebody to do either EMDR or
somebody to do some sort of Bodywork
with you
and body work is sometimes they hold
your hand they put their hand on your
shoulder they put your hand on your back
your head while you are laying down
while you're sitting down while you tell
what happened
and you're you process those feelings as
though they have as they happened again
but you do it in the safety of somebody
else's space
okay okay and what it does is it
eventually discharges that that trauma
that's held in your body
and it might be an overuse of the word
but feeling like your body failed you is
a core trauma trauma means I'm separate
from myself
and feeling like I can't take this step
because my knee is going to blow out on
me again feeling like I can't do
something hard because last time I did
my body almost shut me down in the like
30 000 feet in the air
is that's that's thick that's the trauma
right and every time you think about it
your body remembers the past and it
drags it into the present
and so we have to unhook our response
from that you weren't safe then you're
you're great now
now let's figure out what that is and
dude it's okay to be jealous it's okay
to be like ah they did it I didn't
that's okay you're not broken or crazy
you need to grieve that
I would love to see you take some
autonom I mean some ownership some
autonomy so um not autonomy that's the
wrong word I want you to take some
ownership here's what this is I want you
to write Justin the pilot a letter
and I want you to say Dear Justin the
pilot
we were supposed to be flying today
and be very specific and
I chose to not fly
I chose a different life path I chose
health and healing I chose fill in the
blank
and I want you to begin to not
be subjected to a body that you don't
trust I want you to take ownership of
that body again
in a weird way anxiety tends to follow
the leader
and if the leader is firm and committed
in taking ownership anxiety says we
don't have to ring the alarms because
that guy's driving
it's when your body thinks dude he's not
paying attention he's not paying
attention then it will start shutting
you down
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah absolutely
because I think there's a lot of
grieving you haven't done yet I think
you may have talked with a counselor for
a while and y'all just talked and how
does it make you feel and how's that
make you feel but let's get in and do
the hard work which is we're going to
grieve this thing I'm gonna take
ownership of it because you aren't
kicked out
your body said we're out and then you
did a noble thing and you walked away
and so you made a choice and now you're
making a choice to go be a mental health
counselor which is awesome we need some
more great counselors out there and
you're going to make a choice to get to
the core anxiety and you're going to
make a choice to release your body from
responding to this nonsense every time
you think about a pilot or every time
you see a plane fly over every time
you're about to get on a plane and your
body goes whoosh and drops and that that
slow motion feeling we're gonna be done
with that now
I'm gonna go process I'm gonna go back
to that feeling back to that moment and
I'm gonna free my body from it and by
the way we're gonna get to what in the
world is my body so scared of
I landed the plane the teacher said I
did great my schooling said I did great
they certified me and everything why is
my body so scared of and my guess is
you're going to find something in your
environment that's much much bigger
somebody who didn't believe in you for a
long period of time and cast a narrative
into you that became part of your
nervous system or you're lonely or you
don't take care of your body or any
number of things
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of building a non-anxious life as
well I want you to read that book and
see if any of that Rings true
but my guess is there's a deeper well
here's a deeper picture
and I don't want to put um I don't want
to put hope where
you have put something to bed but
and you get to this core anxiety
maybe you're back up there flying again
or maybe
you deal with that core anxiety and a
couple years from now in your licensed
counselor you're sitting across the room
from somebody
and you're able to look into their eyes
and say I've been there too
I've been there too I'm Friday man you
did a hard hard thing you have a hard
um road to go into the future and you
can do it you can do it be right back
hey Dr John deloney here I'm super
jazzed to announce my new book building
a non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order listen we all experience some
level of anxiety or stress or burnout
every day but most of us don't know how
to recognize it let alone deal with it
and here's the good news anxiety doesn't
have the last word I know this because
I've sat with thousands of you and I
know this because I've been there too if
you create a life of intentionally
living out the six daily choices I've
outlined in this book you'll be able to
better respond at whatever life throws
at you this book will help you learn
practical steps to overcome anxiety plus
when you pre-order the book now I'm
gonna give you something to help you
today that's why you'll instantly get my
newest talk smoke fire and freedom where
I break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-anxious life today for just 20 bucks
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
finally Kelly's out today and there's
good music well done Jenna
the Great and Powerful Smiths I love the
Smiths man I love The Smiths
songs called asleep I'm assuming this is
a shout out to the first caller
of course yes of course are you a
Smith's fan
actually Andrew over here picked it
I knew it Andrew rules Andrew rules
where are you on that one Jenna you
should get an associate producer credit
on this show today way to go Andrew
song's called asleep and it goes like
this sing me to sleep I'm tired I want
to go to bed sing me to sleep and then
leave me alone don't try to wake me in
the morning
cause I'll be gone don't feel bad for me
I want you to know deep in the cell of
my heart I feel so glad to go
I don't want to wake up on my own
anymore sing to me I don't even know
what they're talking about at this point
I'll go to sleep leave me alone I
wanna come back let's be friends
actually this sounds more like Jenna
than I care to admit
it's all good love you guys see you soon
bye
[Music]